what a day what a day a bombshell report
claims that Donald Trump knowingly
conducted illegal business in communist
Cuba during Fidel Castro's reign in the
nineteen nineties there is a Newsweek
cover story today by curt i can walt who
has been a guest on this program and it
is called the castro connection and it
claims and if this is true it is
devastating for Donald Trump and I'll
tell you more about why in a second the
story claims that Donald Trump spent at
least sixty eight thousand dollars in
1998 for a business foray into Cuba even
though corporate activity in Cuba was
completely illegal without government
approval at the time we've only recently
under President Obama started to see a
loosening of the Cuban embargo and every
indication according to the article is
that with Donald Trump's knowledge
executives from Trump hotels in casino
resorts funneled cash through an
American consulting firm called seven
arrows investment and development
corporation into Cuba the report is
damning it claims that seven arrows
consultants would travel to Cuba to look
for potential business opportunities and
then explain to trump here's how we're
going to sort of get a rap get around
our actual intentions here by linking
these business efforts to completely
bogus and made-up charitable efforts now
for people who will hear this they say
David it sounds really really
far-fetched remember Donald Trump has a
very long history of very weird stuff
going on with charitable donations he's
got this Donald J Trump foundation uh
which number one he has not donated to
since 2008 which number two has clearly
been used as a way to buy political
capital with favors and donors money
number three he seems to have
drastically overstated his donations to
veterans and tried to make up for that
during the campaign by on stage at a
rally donating to a Veterans
organization which in and of itself may
have been illegal because he was using
charitable donations for political gain
on stage at a rat
so there's no shock there's no surprise
that part of this entire alleged Cuba
incident also involves misusing supposed
charitable donations now as if this
weren't already enough the article by
Kurt icon walled says that this all
happened right before Donald Trump
launched his first uh presidential bid
seeking the nomination of the Reform
Party so potentially incriminating
allegations here this is after Donald
Trump at the debate on Monday said he
was smart for not paying federal taxes
this has the potential to
single-handedly crush the Donald Trump
campaign this is what i like to call
casually as light to medium treason it
has serious implications criminal
penalties for violation of these
sanctions range up to 10 years in prison
up to a million dollars in corporate
fines up to 250 thousand dollars in
individual fines and of course and more
than likely it would be this way if we
ever were to see any charges anyway
civil penalties of up to 55 thousand
dollars per violation but all legal
implications aside this could destroy
Trump's chances in Florida Cuban
floridians who generally speaking Cubans
are the most conservative of Hispanic
groups they're very anti-castro finding
out that Donald Trump was doing business
with Fidel Castro could single-handedly
turn Florida towards Hillary Clinton and
if you've looked at the maps it's a
pretty tough path to 270 electoral votes
for Donald Trump without Florida yeah
I'm pretty sure this is gonna stick on
its own but we know that he has a
history of doing these things that may
have conflict of interest that's why he
has to release his tax return so the
public knows that simply using the
excuse that while I'm being audited by
the IRS it's not gonna cut it anymore
we're going to actually dig more into
that tomorrow it's not like Donald Trump
has never released his taxes he's
actually released his taxes for other uh
uh in in other situations and we're
gonna get into that tomorrow but as Pat
is pointing out seemingly continue
to say absolutely no taxes at all for
this presidential race that i'm in
involved here uh so number one if this
sticks and we will see these are
allegations we're going to see what the
response is as of right now there has
been no response yet from the Trump
campaign about the story this will hurt
Donald Trump with Cuban Americans in
Florida that is going to be a problem in
Florida specifically but it also would
give Hillary Clinton huge huge huge
ammunition for ads and whatever else uh
can can be used in future debates
etcetera Cubans in Florida really really
really hate Fidel Castro and this is not
going to be good for Donald Trump in
what is a very very very important state
I would do a wellness check on Ted Cruz
right now I bet he is not thrilled after
he he he sort of abstained from
endorsing Donald Trump for so long
finally says Yamin a vote for the guy
and then now a few days later it comes
out the Trump may have been illegally
doing business with the dell Castro in
Cuba absolutely amazing if you turn this
into a movie script it would be rejected
because it's just who would buy this
stuff it's just not believable